yannick noah personnalité préférée des
français est en deuil sa mère marie
claire est décédé lundi à l'âge de 75
ans des suites d'une longue maladie elle
avait fondé en 1988 avec son fils dans
les yvelines à thiverval grignon
l'association les enfants de la terre
pour venir en aide aux enfants isolés de
leurs parents ou en danger et c'est
d'ailleurs cette association qui a
officialisé le décès en publiant sur son
site internet une photo de marie claire
noah et ce message
les enfants de la terre sont orphelins
nous avions rencontré marie claire noah
à plusieurs occasions sur tv fil 78 je
propose de l'écouter c'était en 2001
elle nous parlait de son engagement et
de la création de l'association de ses
origines on a passé dix soirées entre
copains à chercher des noms les plus
farfelues puis finalement comme au
départ quand on a créé une cette
nouvelle association
on ne savait pas vers où on se dirigeait
vers l'étranger vers la france vers les
enfants le savez donc on a dit bon
puisqu'on sait que c'est une association
pour les enfants
on va tout simplement appeler les
enfants de la terre les critères il y en
a pas beaucoup c'est ce sont des enfants
qui vivent sur notre territoire des
enfants de vie vendus en france qu'ils
soient étrangers ou non mais vivant sur
notre territoire et en gros n'ayant pas
la chance de nos propres enfants
c'est-à-dire en effet il y en ait des
problèmes sociaux de problèmes familiaux
et des problèmes médicaux et qui me sont
envoyés par des structures différentes
on ne veut pas que ce soit des maisons
famille d'accueil parce qu'une famille
d'accueil accueille deux trois enfants
mais pour longtemps on ne veut surtout
pas avoir le label colonie de vacances
accueille deux grosses quantité
d'enfants donc on accueille une
quinzaine d'enfants et ses enfants chez
nous nous vivent un petit peu comme dans
une famille